they bought it for 24 and a half and
then just got a loan from t-side money
for 37 and a half which means you pulled
out
so 10 grand
hey what's up youtube this is just as
impromptu spontaneous video to be honest
right now i'm kind of upset i'm upset
not with this dude
you look upset as well i'm upset who are
we upset with
i'm well upset who are we upset with
tick-tock tick-tock what is wrong with
you tick-tock listen let me tell you
what happened
really important
people are saying i'm a conspiracist but
this dude was with me this dude was with
me here's what happened
i went to one of my students houses okay
he was the perfect student her name is
nozzy she's from zimbabwe i met her i've
helped to become financially free she
did some rent to rent she came on
windows wednesday and she's financially
free now she starts doing brr deals
she bought a house
okay
up north she bought a house for
24
000 pounds okay she bought it for 24
grand
she spent 2 thousand pounds refurbishing
it didn't need much work doing to it at
all
then she refinanced it how much how is
she was it was it fifty grand
fifty grand
okay fifty grand now i start talking
about this
on uh on tick tock
and everyone was saying i don't believe
the figures that sounds too good to be
true that's how most people operate if
something's really good they say it
sounds too good to be true so
people aren't really believing it it
does sound extreme
so me and my man darwin what did we do
bro
we went round to a house right we turned
up our house we're like hey nazi you
know we went to the house i went in
i met with the tenants okay the tenants
were in there i saw the ast contract the
tenants were paying 400 pounds a month
i asked nazi to show me the title deeds
she showed me the title deeds she's the
owner of the property and she bought the
property for 24 000 pounds
okay i met her husband i met everybody i
saw the receipts i saw the refinance
value from her new lender
not only was it a free house
when she refinanced it she got all her
money back plus 10 grand
okay so this house is like a brilliant
deal she shows me all the receipts
the lending everything on the house
so what did i do i did a tick tock video
this house was literally bought by my
good friends for 24 and a half thousand
pounds is that correct did you really
buy 24.5 pounds yes
you spent a couple grand doing it up
carpet paint and how much is it worth
now 50 000 pounds
i'm like look tic toc i showed the
receipts that's all i did
you bought it november 25th yeah
so they bought it november 25th for 24
and a half thousand pounds
okay
and then you had a loan against it
so they bought it for 24 and a half
literally a few months ago november
2020
and then
just got a loan
from t-side money
for 37 and a half
which means you pulled out
all of your money yeah
plus
12 and a half minus your refurb say 10
grand
that's ridiculous
so basically they got paid ten thousand
pounds to have the house
right darwin yeah all right darwin's
really pissed off because donald made
the video
we showed all the receipts
we should we just and i just did a tick
tock video i was just like look here the
receipts bang bang bang
then tick tock
removed the video
bam bam bam removed it
i appealed it i said ticked up what are
you doing and they said that it was
illegal activity
okay tick tock said illegal activity
let me tell you something tick-tock
and skeptics okay
this is how
all
rich people make money in property
this is the strategy
mcdonald's do this folks
mcdonald's build cheap restaurants and
then push the value up by putting a
tenant in it but it's basically brr they
buy it they push the value up how do
they do it by putting commercial 20-year
leases on there
and then they've got the equity which
they can refinance or whatever right so
um grant cardone robert kiyosaki
james khan james khan talked about his
very first deal in his book the real
deal and how did he do it james khan did
his first project he was basically a big
massive brr deal by refurbishing finance
rent he pulled out all his money plus a
million pounds now for the rich people
to do it's all okay right james khan can
talk about in his book and it's all okay
mcdonald's can do it it's all okay
but as soon as people start doing it who
are poor not poor is in like oh they're
destitute but no nazi didn't have any
money she had to get a loan out to buy
that house at 24 grand house she
borrowed some money off her kids to help
with the refurb you can hear a story on
windows on a wednesday so as soon as
people start doing it normal ordinary
people okay then suddenly it's a scam
then suddenly it's not real
and then as soon as you publish the
receipts
and say look here's how it's real boom
they then say it's illegal
tick
tick-tock
social media platforms
it's not illegal it's what all rich
people do
and and and why is it that when you
don't provide proof
people just say i don't believe it
and then when you provide proof people
just say
you know oh wow that's illegal
what
get real
so this is normal
it's standard this is how everyone
should buy houses should buy a house
push the value up and then pull your
money out otherwise you're leaving your
money in the property you don't want to
just sink 50 grand into a house and just
leave it and then go and work really
hard and save up another 50 grand what
you want to do is you want to put 50
grand to a house and then you want to
push the value of the house using other
people's money or using development
finance companies or bridging finance
and then you want to pull back your 50
grand and keep recycling it again and
again and again and again this is the
way to invest in property it's not
illegal
it's not a scam
and anyone can do it you can do with big
deals you can do with medium deals or
you can do a little tiny 24 grand houses
deals up in the north of england
it is legitimate i am appealing tick
tock right now but more than tick tock i
don't care what tick tock think
more than tick tock i want you
watching this video right now
to know that it's possible and to know
that you can do it too
so
i'm going to keep rebelling against the
system
i'm going to keep showing videos if you
want to see uh um oh my man's gone now
but i don't know where he's got if you
want to see the original video it's
obviously been removed from tick tock i
think it is on instagram so if you head
down to my instagram you can just scroll
down and
you'll get to see the video with me and
nausea but uh it's incredible so listen
i'm going to leave a little video up so
you can watch my full interview with
nazi so you can see what she's doing
i'll leave a little link up for it also
if you want to come and join me
and learn about how to do these
strategies then come and join me at some
training and don't forget to subscribe
to the channel where i'm going to keep
telling you exactly how to make money in
real estate